[Música]
los nicaragüenses acuden a las urnas
para las elecciones presidenciales del
próximo 7 de noviembre en las que el
mandatario daniel ortega busca ser
reelegido por cuarta vez consecutiva
tras una campaña marcada por una ola de
arrestos contra los principales
precandidatos ante todo esto el gobierno
sandinista es acusado de liderar y crear
una campaña virtual a través de cuentas
falsas en facebook para así favorecer la
candidatura de ortega y además atacar a
las voces opositoras son 4.3 millones de
nicaragüenses los que están habilitados
para votar en este proceso electoral
calificado por eeuu como una farsa
además de eso también por la unión
europea ha calificado como una farsa de
elecciones para ello quiero darle la
bienvenida a nuestro segundo invitado el
día ls tiziano breda analista para
américa central de international crisis
group gracias tiziano por estar aquí con
nosotros en directo américa vamos a
hablar entonces del panorama previo a
todas estas elecciones nicaragüenses del
próximo domingo
bueno muchísimas gracias por la
invitación roble un placer acompañarle
efectivamente no es la primera vez que
ortega intenta digamos desbalancear un
poco el escenario electoral para
favorecer claramente al frente
sandinista de liberación nacional pero
la diferencia con esta elección es que
el país llega a esta elección en el
marco de una crisis sociopolítica y
económica que digamos empezó en 2018
cuando estas protestas masivas contra el
gobierno fueron fuertemente reprimidas
por las posibilidades dejando más de 300
personas desparecidas
esto ha hecho que el costo y la
probabilidad para ortega de perder poder
en un comicio digamos competitivo
transparente y justo aumentarán
considerablemente la probabilidad porque
la popularidad básicamente ha caído a la
mitad de lo que era antes de 2018 y el
costo porque
digamos los hechos del 2018 la represión
estatal ha sido considerada por la cdh
como posiblemente crímenes de lesa
humanidad lo que implicaría que tenga
fuera del poder podría ser se puede
enfrentar hasta el juicio de juicio si
la institución judicial en este respecto
lo que le ha empujado a escalar está en
esta represión y de digamos minimizar a
cero cualquier posibilidad de perder
el poder a través de cancelación de
personalidad jurídica de partidos y
sobre todo desde extensión de líderes
opositores incluido es siete
presidenciables
tiziano es decir que estamos llegando a
estas elecciones del próximo domingo sin
ningún tipo de garantías del proceso
si este proceso no cumple con ningún
tipo de estándar internacional además
que el lugar no se ha negado a tener una
invitar una observación internacional
técnicamente preparada sino que lo ha
debilitado a un acompañamiento internet
electoral de parte de personas y grupos
más que todo a fin que afinados
alineados ideológicamente
y no nos han dejado entrar mil por
ejemplo la prevista internacionales o
sea vamos aún a una elección de partido
único básicamente que se pretende sea
multipartidaria y participativa y hay
unos otros 56 partidos que participan
pero en realidad de facto es una
elección del partido donde los mexicanos
no cuentan opción para votar claro
porque además tiziano recordemos que
estos partidos están de alguna manera u
otra relacionados con el frente
sandinista el partido el partido también
del gobierno de daniel ortega pero usted
cree que viendo todo este panorama un
poco d alentador en términos
democráticos en algunos ciudadanos se
pueden acudir a las urnas que tanto
apoyo además le pregunto tiene daniel
ortega dentro de la ciudadanía
efectivamente este será digamos lo que
llamará la pensión para ver el domingo
porque por un lado habrá que ver qué
tanta es la capacidad todavía de
movilización del gobierno y después
sandinista que ha mantenido unos niveles
de simpatía entre un 20 y 30 por ciento
de todas las propuestas a laurent
durante años a pesar de las cuestiones
actuales
y por otro lado para ver cuál es la real
influencia que todavía los grupos de
oposición tienen sobre la ciudadanía
ya que estos grupos varios de ellos casi
todos han llamado a la gente a no salir
de casa no ir a votar ni siquiera ir a
votar nulo que realmente vaciar las
calles y las pistas durante fotos
entonces habrá que ver digamos cuál es
todavía el potencial de movilización de
parte del gobierno y de parte de la
oposición espera
si ahora tiziano también hablemos de las
sanciones que ha impuesto a eeuu y
también en la unión europea a ortega a
su gobierno a algunos miembros de su
familia el presidente ortega ha dicho
que no se va a dejar intimidar por estas
sanciones que le pone pues digamos la
comunidad internacional 100 nos debe
intimidar y está digamos en esta tónica
pues qué va a pasar podemos seguir
viendo a ortega por cuánto tiempo más
pues efectivamente las sanciones han
tenido una trayectoria con resultados
mixtos en el sentido de que en principio
cuando fueron las primeras rondas
impuestas por estados unidos a finales
de 2018
tuvieron un papel en contribuir a
presionar ortega
por ejemplo a reanudar un diálogo por
una posición al llegar a ciertos
acuerdos de uno de los cuales se cumplió
parcialmente el autonómicas cumplió
pero digamos tuvieron un impacto
positivo desde entonces pero
digamos en su acumulación y progresiva
imposición realmente en piso que el
gobierno se atrincherara cada vez más
en sus posiciones y fortaleciera sus
retóricas narrativa victimista
antiimperialista de los eventos de la
dirección shogi y actual entonces la el
tema es que las sanciones por ahora han
sido individuales oa personajes hoy a
las cartas tiradas pero no económicas
sectoriales o sea que no han golpeado
sector económico o día para algunos
pero también claramente generaría muchos
problemas a nivel de empleo
en teoría humanitaria entonces dependerá
si la presión internacional es
coordinada y es funcional a una
estrategia una hoja de ruta que pueda
servir para encontrar una solución
negociada y no solamente claro